Більше грошей на енергоефективність -
українські екологи від пам'ятника Бетховену
адресують меседж уряду в Києві.
Іллі Яременку з Рівного та активістам з інших міст
довелося їхати аж до Бонна,
щоб їхній заклик було почуто.
У першу чергу ми очікуємо підтримки в екологічних
питаннях від Володимира Гройсмана.
Власне, до нього з ось цією акцією ми й звертаємося.
І закликаємо його почати виділяти
більше грошей на енергоефективність.
Тому що це універсальний спосіб і планету рятувати,
і людям допомагати економити.
У Бонні вже другий тиждень триває
глобальний кліматичний саміт ООН.
Ідеться про скорочення шкідливих викидів в атмосферу.
Скорочуються вони й в Україні.
Формально українці Паризьку кліматичну угоду не порушують.
Але, на переконання екологів, Київ взяв на себе
надто скромні зобов'язання.
Тому що та ціль, яку Україна оголосила в Паризькій угоді,
не передбачає ані заходів з енергозбереження,
ані розвиток відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Вона дозволятиме у півтора рази збільшити викиди парникових газів.
Що є недопустимим з точки зору збереження клімату на планеті.
Українці приєднуються до видовищної
міжнародної демонстрації.
Для Іллі Єременка це вже другий подібний саміт.
Він переконався, що екологи у багатьох країнах світу можуть
впливати на позиції офіційних делегацій своїх країн.
Політики там ведуть діалог з неурядовими організаціями.
Але не в Україні.
Cтосовно української делегації, то нам дуже складно на неї впливати.
І навіть зустрітися з нею досить складно.
Можливо, коли в Україні політики
демонструватимуть більшу відданість питанням
довкілля, вищий пріоритет їм надаватимуть,
то і делегація буде більш відкритою до співпраці з нами.
Екологи додають, що, порівняно з урядом часів Януковича,
влада стала відкритішою до громадських організацій,
а проблема глобального потепління
з'явилася на порядку денному.
Однак лобістам традиційних джерел енергії
вдається і далі пробивати свої інтереси на найвищому рівні.
Насправді для України розвиток відновлюваних
джерел енергії – це і енергонезалежність, і розвиток
зелених робочих місць і це збереження довкілля.
Тому що атомна енергетика це дуже небезпечно для довкілля.
Вугілля в нас практично вже немає. Від газу ми залежимо.
Тому для нас цей перехід це насправді
єдиний шлях розвитку України.
До кінця саміту екологи сподіваються обмінятися
досвідом із багатьма однодумцями.
Кліматичні зміни, наголошують активісти,
стосуються не лише острівних держав,
а й безпосередньо України.
За прогнозами Світового банку,
середньорічна температура в Україні до 2100 року
може підвищитисяна 3-4 градуси за Цельсієм.
Тож, Україна мала б вже на цій конференції заявити
збільшення своїх зусиль із захисту клімату,
кажуть активісти.
Якщо ж цього не станеться, це буде для них
великим розчаруванням.